YOU CAN TIME US.
YEAH, HERE YOU GO.
- YES.
- WHAT IS THIS?
- OH, RANCHO CUCAPIZZA
IS HAVING A LITTLE PROMOTIONAL
EATING CONTEST,
AND THE WINNER GETS--
READ THAT BOTTOM LINE THERE.
READ THAT.
WELL, IT SAID, UH,
WINS FREE PIZZA FOR A YEAR!
- YEAH, ALL WE GOTTA DO IS EAT
A HUMONGA CUCAMONGA
IN UNDER 30 MINUTES.
- SEE, THEY MAKE THE PIZZA
SO HOT
THAT ALL THE OTHER
DUMB BUFFOONS,
THEY'LL JUST BURN THEIR PIPES.
- BUT WE ARE NO IDIOTS.
OUR MOUTHS
WILL ALREADY BE BURNED.
- YEP, VIA SPOONS.
- MM-HMM.
- WE'RE GONNA PUT
THESE HOT SPOONS
ON OUR TONGUES.
- YEP.
- WE'RE GONNA BURN THEM
SO THAT THE PIZZA
WON'T BURN THEM.
OKAY, ALICE,
START THE CLOCK.
- YEAH, START IT.
- WE NEED YOU TO TIME US.
OH, SHE STARTED,
SHE STARTED, START.
[guys screaming]
- OH, GOD!
OH, THAH WATH THO HOT!
- WHAT DO WE GOT?
- WHAT DO WE GOT FOR TIME?
WHAT'S THE TIME?
OH, SHE DIDN'T THART THE CLOCK.
- WHAT? SHE DIDN'T THART IT?
- YEAH, IT WAS PERFECT.
IT'S GONNA SOUND REAL GOOD
ON THE PHONES.
JAGMOS.
- I DON'T LIKE HOW
SHE ALWAYS PUTH UTH DOWN
WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO BETTER OURTHEVLES HERE.
- AND WHO ARE THE IDIOTS HERE?
- ROUND TWO.